so hello everybody and welcome to this
lecture which is called insane in the
endgame
my name is Pepe a drum master in Spain
and I'm happy to be here with all of you
so please you have any questions during
this lecture please don't hesitate to
ask this way will be more fun and more
interactive so we're supposed to show a
really crazy end game and this is where
we're doing here in one of the craziest
and games that I ever seen in my life
the gang I'm gonna show you corresponds
to a game that was that was played in
the candidates tournament between
Vladimir Kramnik Russian player x world
champion and Fabiano Khurana you
probably all know for Yano Caruana he
was the last Challenger of Magnus
calcium and this was round 4 in the
candidates tournament in last year in
2018 and after round number 3 kramnik
was living and this was a little
surprised because as you may know he was
one of the oldest players in this
tournament and this game started a quite
slowly quite calm but then after some
moves it went pretty pretty crazy so
let's go
so Kramnik decide to go for a 4th and if
I was played by 4 young Caruana
merit 3 and Knight f6 do you know how
this defense is called yes exactly
Petrov defence is one of the most solid
solid defenses in chess for example a
lot of top Chinese players are using it
these days and it's quite solid
so basically black attacks the e4 pawn
and now white X I mean v d6 also Knight
e4 is possible but could be a little bit
tricky because now you go Queen e2 what
happens after for example Knight f6 yes
yes knight c6 exactly this cover check
and then Black has to resign right
because your blunder in the Queen so
that's why everybody plays here d6 and
now not a3 back Knight takes e4 and here
there are many many possibilities for
white here in this position you can play
d4
you can play t3 even Bishop d3 is not
that stupid
also Knight c3 but in the game Kramnik
went for Queen e2 Knight c3 is is what
almost everybody is playing these days
because after Knight exe 3d text e3 you
are aiming to go Bishop e3 Queen d2 long
castle and then you are hoping for black
to go short castle and then both Kings
will be in opposite flanks and then the
game will be pretty dynamic and
unbalanced but instead kramnik went for
Queen e2 this is not the most aggressive
line but alright so what do you think
black plague here where are your
candidates move moves in this position
you would go d5 to protect the night you
would go f5 or Bishop f5 no none of them
exactly so d3 is some is nasty thread
right so if you go f5 or d5 or Bishop f5
after d3 black has to resign so that's
why the only move is yes Queen is 7
right this is the only move and good
move here the mainline goes after d3 and
then Knight f6 and Bishop g5 with a
almost equal position but here kramnik
tried Knight c3 and ok black to concede
3d text c3 Queen takes it to Bishop take
c2 and then probably most of you would
be asking now come on this is gonna be a
crazy endgame this looks so equal so
boring but then after 15 moves you will
see what happens here
so ok this is pretty balanced now right
so black went knight c6 now Bishop e3
was played by Vladimir crack make Bishop
e7 long castle sure castle and rook H 2
e 1 this is a pretty natural move
bringing the route to the center to the
open file right now
black improved a little bit the position
of this Bishop with 9 f6
and here white when 92 what do you think
what is intended to do in this position
yes
94 exactly that comes with a tempo
because you would be attacking the
bishop on f6 and if you get the bishop
prayer you will be much better
or at least a little bit better the
bishop pair is quite important in chess
so normally and to Bishop to Bishop
sorry are a little bit better than a
bishop and a knight of course this
always depends on the exact position but
normally it's like that right so now how
do you prevent Knight e4 okay there are
two ways right or let's say three ways
so who votes for Bishop f5 or rukhi
eight yes so rook e8 or Bishop a5 Bishop
f5 okay this is not the best move
because because it allows pawns turn on
the King side now g4 is really annoying
for black because if you go back then f4
is coming and then you have gained a lot
of space for example after Bishop f6 g6
or f4 and now black would be in deep
trouble let's say after 86 you can push
f5 and then this visual is not gonna
play the rest of the game so that's why
I be sharp f5 was not a very good move
but instead Kramnik went for Rukia the
best move in the position stopping
Knight e4 and now Bishop f3 was played
in order to continue with this 94 idea
at this point black went Knight e5
attacking this Bishop but for example if
you go Bishop d7 what would you play
here with white we said the idea was to
go 94 right so why not to go 94 94 let's
say B should be 7 and you can't even
play here night c5 attacking gives this
Bishop on d7 it black takes on c5 again
we win the bishop pair and then we have
a rook on the seventh trunk this is
always a great idea on the end games
right okay so instead of Bishop least d7
black went 95 and now what do we play
here with the white pieces would you
allow black to take your Bishop on f3 we
said the bishop pair is really
important so we have to keep that bishop
pair so where do we move our f3 Bishop
to h5 to e2 going back doesn't seem like
a good idea right we just went from e2
to ad-free so going back to it - doesn't
sound reasonable
so h5 it's not a very good square either
so where do we go yes exactly
so d4 d5 looks good this actually was a
crumb mix idea and then he thought okay
after c6 as happen in the game I just go
to b3 he changed diagonals now this
Bishop is on b3 is also enjoying a good
diagonal and now of course white thread
still Knight e4 right okay Bishop d5 was
one of the ideas but before that gromek
went Bishop f4 this was another way of
stopping matter three
why not a three is not possible because
there is checkmate on e8
right so now it's a little bit hard for
black to develop the pieces because now
you can't move the bishop from c8 since
b7 is hanging so why this written to go
Knight e4 so that's why here Fabiano
Caruana went key in effect now he's
saying alright now I protected my rook
on EA and now I'm actually threatened to
take this guy on that three so that's
why now kramnik went Bishop g5 and after
c6 Bishop b3 the idea that we just saw
so now there are two ways of stopping 94
one is d5 and the other one is Bishop f5
and both are very reasonable in the game
for yellow Caruana went for Bishop f5
the other idea was d5 and then after c4
in order to open this they're gonna D
takes e4 Knight takes e4 Knight takes
rook takes King takes Bishop takes maybe
why this is a little bit better because
of this black skin situation in the
center but nothing special but instead
Fabiano Caruana
like Bishop f5 and here what will you
play with the white pieces would you go
94 would you go Bishop 86
no right would you go Bishop takes e5
giving the bishop pair for nothing
doesn't seem like a good idea right so
actually Knight e4 was not a very good
idea and of course gromek didn't go for
that because after Bishop takes e4 Ruth
takes e4 d5 now this Bishop is basically
doing nothing is it's gonna be really
hard for white to strike in the center
with c4 and then there are even some
tricks what happens if white retreats
the route to eat you yes 93 winning on
the spot check and then after takes here
or texts with the Rope then rookie - you
can still play King D - but then rook
takes it to King taxi - and then Knight
takes f4
right so that's why Bishop 94 was not a
very good idea of course after d5 rook
e1 would be much much better but then
after Knight g4 let's say Bishop g3 and
Bishop e5 black is a little bit better
because you're gonna trade the dark
square bishop and then your knight would
be much better than the bishop on b3
this Bishop is actually locked out by by
his own pawns right
so instead after Bishop f5 Kramnik went
h3 here and what do you think crime
against intending to do here in the next
in the next month yes
g4 exactly you play something passive
here are natural like rook a d8 being a
bring the rook to the center protecting
d6 now g4 would be very very annoying
for black let's say Bishop g6 and now a
very good move what do we do now with
the white pieces we want to send our
pawn storm on the key inside
yes Bishop g3 a very good move now the
threat is to go f4 attacking this night
when this night goes back then
f5 wins apiece and it's extremely hard
for black to to defend let's say it six
you can go F for this night has to go
back you can't even play a fit at five
Bishop 87 and then get this form so
that's why after a tree black has to be
really really careful and Fabiano
Caruana when g5 a good move attacking
this bishop now this bishop is gonna
have this GC x squared and then the pawn
storm is not gonna be that dangerous on
the Kings side so g5 Bishop h2 and now
King g7 improving in the situation of
that team and again now you go 94 which
was not played in the game black could
actually take takes and d5 and again
this Bishop let's say after rook e1 b5
now you're never gonna be able to play
c4 and this Bishop is out of the game
and actually black is better so that's
why after King g7 white went c4 a very
interesting move saying you know what
now when I go 94 and then you take take
I'm gonna have I'm gonna have the bishop
pair and then you won't be able to to
play d5 and then this bishop can always
come back to to life after c3 and Bishop
c2 right let's say for example if black
does something passive like rook a to
the a then 90 for Bishop takes rook
takes and then a plant for the white
player could be c3 Bishop C to improving
the position of this bishop and then you
have the bishop pair and black has
nothing in return so that's why after
keen c7 see for now the game start
starts getting a little while so Fabiano
Caruana
decides go for g4 here of course after H
takes e4 Knight takes e4 it's blacks
idea attacking 82 and f2 and here
white when 94 now what do we do with the
black pieces we have to take that Bishop
takes rook takes Bishop g5 check from
Fabiano card wanna Kim b1 only move on
here what do you think can you take on
h3 or what do we play here with black it
seems like we have to do something if we
can take on h3 then we're much worse
right the thing is if black takes on h3
you have to calculate F 4 with a fork
attacking the knight and the bishop but
can we take an x-ray enough
here the position looks complicated
you'll see later I've been analyzing
this game today for two hour and still
get nothing
so you mean G takes X 3 and then F 4 and
then you want to take this pawn on G 2
right yeah but then I just take this guy
here on e5 sorry
basically I'm gonna play it rook g1 and
collect this guy in g2 right but very
interesting ok so is it possible to take
an h3 or not this is the critical
situation so G takes f 4 maybe now you
will see a little bit clearer maybe
you'll find a solution now for black
there is a solution for black actually
f4 it's actually really bad move in this
position yes
f5 ok
f5 interesting but now what happens if I
f5 is interesting okay but I think now
yeah and after rookie 2 for example what
do you want to do yeah 94 his daily
actually f4 is strongly met with Knight
g4 straight away so now you have to take
on ei rook takes e8 and the thing is
this Bishop is hanging but also yours
and after f2 x c5 Knight x h2
gtex h3 after 9 ft these two points are
extremely weak and then probably you're
gonna end up taking both of them and
basically you you can take on d6 because
they checkmate only one background
problems so that's why G takes 83 was
play and now f4 was not actually a very
good move in step Kramnik here
complicated the game a lot of course GTX
h3 was possible but then for example
your idea as you said a 5 and then
Luke II - and neither three takes takes
this bishop is under attack and you
complain ID to check King a1 and Knight
e4 and white is gonna struggle to
protect this f2 upon and basically
blacks a bit better you could also think
that after G takes a three f5 Bishop
takes e5 is interesting with a check D
takes e5 group d7 check looks like white
is pretty pretty active in this position
but the thing is after King f6 rook e1 e
for black is actually much much better
even though you take this pawn all eight
seven these two points are very very
strong and then you have also some rook
h8 ideas also after the trade some
Bishop h4 ideas and then if you manage
to make this guy am f2 it will be game
over for white so that's why here at
this point Kramnik decides to go for a
crazy move he goes for c5 this night of
course after D after this c5 move is not
very stable on e5 as you can see here d6
was its support so the game continues
with f5 attacking the rook and then
where would you go with the rook now
whoa this is not sorry
let's go
and we were here at 5:00 you go you will
go to e 2 to e 1 to a 4
and actually chromic was supported by
almost everybody in this candidates
tournament because his this he has been
known for being a really solid player
during his whole career and in this last
candidates tournament he was playing
extremely happy extremely aggressive
trying to go for the win in every game
so do you see where to go with your rook
yes route before is the best move it's
actually the only move because if you go
back let's say - E - then 94 is really
strong now you're attacking the bishop
on H - rook takes rook takes and now
this Bishop is under attack if you go
let's say we should take c6 after H
takes you to this pawn is almost going
to promote so that's why good before
that's drum mix idea and then H takes G
to was played and group b7 check and
here again it's a critical moment for
black there is only one good move and
then maybe you are going to find it and
then you're going to tell me the reason
why that's the only good wolf
who wants to play rookie seven who wants
to play King h8 Kingi a king g8 is not a
legal move king g6 King eight six King
f6 there are so many possibilities right
and just one of them is a correct one
you have to keep in mind that f4 could
be a threat right so there is only one
move that Paris that threat
yes King f6 okay
and then what happens after f4
[Music]
you want to move the bishop we're here
you you have only two squares eight six
or eight four yeah h4 is actually a good
square but the thing is now white is
taking with a check that piece D takes
e5 and for example I guess route g1 and
there's no way of stopping rook taxi -
I'm actually blacks appears down right I
got two bishops and then two rooks you
got two rooks and only one bishop and
also have to look taxi to this the
threat of rook f7 checkmate so that's
why King f6 is not a very good move you
see that f4 is actually winning a piss
so we're gonna do something about this
where to move the King now yes
King h8 that's the best move and you go
to eight six you got the same problem
because now after effort what yeah you
take with the check so now the King h8
after f4 sorry after f4 what what can we
play with the black pieces Knight g4
that's exact that's precisely the idea
that's why you have to go back to h8 you
can't go to g6 neither because after f4
94 days Bishop f7 check first in this
scheme to go to a square where we
actually will take the bishop with a
check this King has to go to f6 or eight
six here and then Pontiac c5 and
actually whites women so that's why the
oliva level square is King h8 and this
is where Fabiano Kawana went now f4 is
not very good because of Knight takes e4
Knight g4 sorry F takes an Eric - and
this this night is coming to f3 to
support g1 and black will win so that's
why after keen eh-eh
now Kramnik took on d6 seat xe6
and Knight f3 and what do we do now with
the white pieces this Bishop is hanging
on h2 we have no squares for the bishop
where would you go with the bishop now
Oh what would you do
alright then again I went to a position
that it's not ours now let me just get
back to the current position yeah
can we do something about this night xh2
d7 is an option of course I guess I can
just go look II too
this servant is an option yeah more
options can will come we play Bishop g1
looks like the only squared right
because if we go to g3 then g1 queen and
rook takes Knight takes and just look up
for black so can we go to g1 it's not
the most active square for the bishop
right but actually we can't because
blacks winning after Knight takes D one
simple chest and then rookie to
attacking f2 you can never take g2 yet
because there is made on the background
and then you try to give some fresh air
to your king then Brooke f2 and rook F 1
is coming and also F 4 F 3 and white has
to resign so that's why Bishop g1 was
not possible but instead kramnik found a
really nice way of continuing the game
he went Bishop a4 just passing from that
bishop on h2 and say okay you can take
this bishop but now I'm going to take on
c6 where I'm not only attacking your
rook on ei but also finally I'm going to
manage to to get this pawn from g2 and
then if I manage to take this point on
g2 I will have 5 points and black will
have 3 points okay I a piece down so
that means I'll have 2 points for the
piece but then you see these four points
they are really strong this point of d6
and then this point can also come to
support this guy right and this point is
extremely dangerous that's why the
position is so difficult to understand
and here again Fabiano Caruana finds a
brilliant move in time trouble they were
already in time travel I think Fabiano
Caruana had 4 minutes at this point and
then he had to find a really difficult
move what will you play here with black
this is really tough morphia
okay
so I'm gonna tell you he went for Luke
88 not even moving the rook from the
eighth saying you know what you can take
it but the thing is if white takes this
rook on ei then group d6 is really
strong
because now you can never take because
g1 Quinn and then you move the rook
let's say to eat one you have almost no
squares for the rook then neither three
then dig one is cover c1 is covered g1 X
cover f1 is covered h1 is covered
basically white has to recite here
there's no space there's no room for
this rook and then if you of course go
let's say to e 2 then t1 Queen and
checkmate
so that's why after rook a d8 d7 was
played and now rook e to finally white
manages to take this dangerous pawn and
g2 and now rook takes F to Bishop c6 was
played by Vladimir Kramnik and here
there are so many ideas for both players
as we were saying now White has only one
pawn for the piece but this point is
extremely dangerous and then white has
many many via many many sorry ideas for
example rook c7 rook c8 c4 c5 etc Ruki
one rook e8 so that's why for no Cara
when I decide to go back with this
Knight to g4 and now rook a7 now we have
four passports and this could also start
running at some point it's actually
really well supported by this guy on c6
so 93 was played and here where do we go
with the rook actually we have not so
many squares we have to stay in the
background of course because then rook F
1 would be made but where do we go to
see one to protect C 2 to H 1 to G 1 to
e 1
okay in the game white when Luke g1 what
happens do you think you can protect the
the c2 point
yes night xe2 that's a really good move
and after root taxi to ruk f1 checkmate
only move rook c1 sorry and then rook
taxi one black wins
so that's why kramnik went route g1
attacking this bishop you can't still
take you cannot take jet right because
there is made on the background and here
actually
Fabiano cara wanna wanted to bring this
skin to help this route so that's why he
went for eight six protecting this
bishop now the black skin is is able to
finally come to support the rookin d8 so
route c7 was played and the thing is now
you can't really take this pollen c2y
rook c8 is a possibility and also rook
c8 yeah it's a possibility and also I
guess rook takes e5 and rook c8 this
just wins
so Brooke system was played and then
King g7 as we were saying now if you go
rook c8 then king f7 what would be
possible if rook takes d5 then Brooke f1
so that's why after rook c7 King g7 now
Kramnik says you know what I know I
cannot win with this rook c8 idea let's
try to run with the a pawn and then here
is who arrives first the F pawn the a
pawn the h1 because now of course blacks
is going to start running as well
so King f7 was played Bishop b5 now now
white is protecting the c2 pawn and King
is 7 by Fabiano Caruana
white went a 5 and here it looks like
this pawn is promoting in like in 3
moves a 6 a 7 rook c8 and then a 8 and
then how we're gonna stop that so this
this is why these top players are so
strong and and so difficult to be here
Fabiano Caruana finds a brilliant
contemplate he goes for Luke f4 and
really strange smooth right but he wants
to go to be for let's say if white
continues with a a six look before and
then if you protect this bishop with c4
Bishop f6 and suddenly there is no way
of protecting b2 and then if you manage
to come with the rukns on b2 white will
have a lot of problems there are some
magnets in that position so that's why
after rook F 4 there is a prophylactic
move against route before c3 yeah really
humble move but really effective so do
you just stop rook before and this is
what we're actually a kramnik plate at
this point Caruana in tank trouble
remember these players get increment
let's say three extra minutes or one
extra one hour extra after move 40 so
normally from move 30 to move 40 they
make a lot of mistakes because you just
have 1 minute 2 minutes in the clock and
it's really tough to play soak in d6 and
here
gromek didn't find the best move he went
for route b7 which is the most natural
move of course just protecting d7
protecting b5 and aiming to go a six and
a seven but droops e6 sorry rook c6 was
really strong here because after of
course you can never take on d7 why you
can't take him d7 where there's a
discovered check backward c4 all right
c4 I can just move my keen I guess and
then I have everything protected but
then after sorry after kim takes e7 rook
eight-six check and then when this game
moves then you'll take this Bishop on g5
so that's why
after rook c6 kingi 7 was possible and
now after a six rook takes e7 probably
przemek didn't find didn't calculate the
whole line and now actually white is
much better after the move rook c8 so
black has to keep an eye on the a6 pawn
so after rook a7 grew create and then
you take this night on e3 and white is
much better but crumby couldn't find
that in time trouble and he went for
route b7 and now rook g4 by Verano
karamaneh offering the trave of brooks
rook e1 and f4
now this F for the f1 is also starting
to run and black straight to me to go as
three F 2 and then rook G 1 and F 1 so
here who arrives first a6 was played by
Brad Amir crummy and now another mistake
by Fabiano Caruana he went for h5 okay
he's saying with this f1 I'm not gonna
make it because this guy on b5 is
actually covering the the f1 squared so
I'm gonna try to go with H 5 H 4 H 3 H 2
and then root G 1 and make a queen but
actually s3 was really good hey 7 this
is the line then we'll go back to the
gain of course but let's analyze this
move at 3 3 a 7 f2 rook takes c3 Bishop
takes III rook b8 apparently white
swinging but then there is read this
resource for black here root G 1 and now
where would you go with your kin there
is one good move there's one bad move
King a 2 or kin c2 1 is good one is bad
one with one move you will have good
chances to win the game with the other
one probably you're going to lose and
imagine you have at two minutes in the
clock in this position this is why chess
is so tough
yes
so King a - looks like the most natural
move right because there is no check as
you say I stopped drew k1 but it's
actually the bad move in the position
why there is this amazing trick now for
black rook takes d7 and then you could
be asking come on Pepe I just promote
but given the fact that now your key
Nissan a - this rook a7 check and then I
get the Queen back and this position is
almost one for black as you can say we
are balancing material then this pawn is
almost promoted so that's why King e2 is
really bad wolf you gotta go to see -
that's the best move and now the best
that black can do is rook g2 trying to
go f1 with a check bishop f1 Bishop e7
Ruby a rook d7 this line and white is
much better because you are a pawn up
and then you have to connected passed
pawns of course it's a crazy line almost
impossible to see even for these
monsters right so a six was played
enough Aviano went 85 87
what are you threatening now with the
white pieces what's your next move
if I play h4 yes rook b8 is a threat so
how do we stop route b8 with rook e8
that's the only move available for black
in this position because now you go rook
b8 i can at least take on a 7 and then
if you promote i can at least take with
the bishop and then i'll have strong
counter play so we cannot forget that
actually blacks app is up right so if we
sacrifice this bishop for these two
dangerous pawns and probably black would
be more than fine
and again here Kramnik makes another
mistake i always say so easy to talk
from outside yeah then when we sit over
there in the board with a lot of
pressure etc etc we make mistakes every
move
basically so here there's a crazy
winning idea I couldn't believe it so
when I saw it it's it's not very natural
so Kramnik went before we looked very
natural do you want to go before so you
cover c5 and then you want to continue
with c4 c5 check but the best move is c4
here incredible move and then the idea
is that for example if you continue
let's say with 8 for now c5 is very
strong White's idea is that after kim
takes e5 now this route c1 and you are
coming to c8 win in the game so that's
why c4 is so strong if you try to stop
that with king c5 sorry then you can
play b4 checked and now this king has to
go from this c6 squared let's say you
take on before or youth or you play King
before the winning move is the same
Bishop c6 and now you're just gonna move
the rook and then this rook is gonna
fall so be before mistake from crumby
now Fabiano continuous with h4 and here
c4 from Vladimir Kramnik
a tree again both running c5 check King
a 5 and now Kramnik goes for this line
which apparently is completely winning
he goes for route ba now only move for
black what's the only move for black
here yes rook takes a 7 and now crummy
ghost Luke g8 and then when I was
analyzing this game I was thinking okay
what's gonna win I mean what can I do
with the black pieces
I'm threatening to take on g5 and then
d8 so how do I stop that let's see if
you guys can find a brilliant solution
that Fabiano Khurana spotted in this in
this in this moment
rook a1 okay well I'll just take your
rook and then you wanted to go nexi -
right yes night see you can actually
it's illegal not even possible so that
was a free route for me I love free
routes
so any ideas okay that the move is just
completely insane
he went for Bishop f6 great move and
then probably some of you could be
saying come on how about if I just take
the rook it's a free rook it's been this
night thinking f5 with a double attack
you're attacking actually the route and
also you have threatening checkmate now
okay b2 and c2 are both covered and here
the only available move for white would
be route takes III it takes III and
actually blacks winning this d8
promotion is covered and then you got
this route k1 you've got h2 coming your
attack in this route white would have to
resign so that's why after Bishop f6
probably both players would be having a
heart attack already by this point
Kramnik went for d8 Queen Bishop takes
and rook takes g4 so blacks an exchange
down only in this position and then he
goes for Bishop f6 now with the same
idea of course what do you want to do in
the next move if I go c6 for example
with black if I go c6 with the white
pieces what would you play key in a5
same idea so that's why here clump
kramnik went for route g6 and now what
happens after King f5 I can play Bishop
d3 check right so that's why instead of
keen f5 Fabiana went for route b7 really
smart move attacking this Bishop on b7
and then collecting this pawn on b4 so
chromic was completely winning few moves
before and now after Bishop e2 rook
takes before if I have to take black or
white I will take black because I'm much
more active hear the engine says the
position is around equal but in practice
this is much easy to play with the black
pieces so King a2 was played there are
many moments
takes to come 92 by Fabiano Caruana
attacking this rukon anyone so nor
discover checked
rooks e1 and nag d4 attack him the
bishop on e - where would you go with
the bishop now not to f3
that's a blunder not to be 5 just give
me a square
G for that sounds reasonable
yeah G for is a reasonable move or
Bishop d3 has happen in the game right
so here Luke a4 I mean now White's
threatening to go rook e1 winning the
whole Bishop because now you don't have
the f5 squared right
so if you play let's say H 2 then I will
go rook e1 check and after key moves
then rook takes f6 winning the game so
that's why UK for was played king b1 and
Knight be three by Fabiano guarana
attacking the rook on c1 and also
including son Luke a1 ideas rook e1
check was played King d5 and now you
can't really take on f6 because as we
says centuries there's some route a one
and rook e1 common in the game chromic
went for king c2 and now after 90 XT for
Kramnik made an important mistake again
where would you go with your King now
this is the last trick that Faviana
tried and it worked out actually so you
have well many squares you can go to c3
2 B 2 C 3 and B 2 you can actually say
that they are not very good because
there is this discovered this visual on
f6 right so you guys have to choose
between D 2 D 1 C 1 or B 1 D 2 is also
not very good because of neither three
right so yes b1 so do you just lost the
game as cramming I mean it's fine
if if kramnik did that we can do that
yeah but b1 was not the best square now
we're going to try to explain why there
are so many subtleties here which are
very hard to explain so Kim be one big
mistake the best move was king c1 now
we're going to try to see why so King c1
the idea is that after
neither three actually you have to
maintain this rook on the on the
background right because there are h2
there is h2 coming so roopd one and
after rook a1 you have Bishop b1 check
the problem with Kim b1 is that after
Knight f3 there is Luke a1 common and
you're actually winning the game so
where do you go here you cannot go to f1
if you go to see wondrous rookie one
teensy - rook takes e1 Kim take C 1 and
H 2 winning because if you go rook 8 6
to stop that point what do we play here
how do we win sorry bishop age for
exactly just building a bridge between
the rook and the point so that's why
after Nana 3 route d1 now cramming is
losing Luke a one check King see - Luke
take c1 grab Mike realized that after
context d1 h 2 was winning so that's why
he tried some last trick with Bishop h6
but this is just a piece down now Rudy -
ambition be to check in b1 and the
position is completely winning 4 black
key in c5 Bishop d7 we can even beat
Vladimir Kramnik in this position would
you beat cramming in this position with
the black pieces I think you will I
think you will yeah yeah we're we're a
piece up we got to pass pawns
yeah even Magnus Carlsen will struggle
against us in this position so 95 Luke
f6 and f3 rook f5 and F 2 and finally
Fabiano Caruana won this game against
Vladimir Kramnik so as you guys so this
started with the solid Petrov and ended
up with a crazy endgame with where White
was trying to to make 4 Queens on the
Queen side and then black was trying to
make Queen on the Kings side so I hope
you guys enjoy enjoy this crazy endgame
thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]